good just let you know i'm having
problems with my ipad
um it's it's taking an age to uh to
charge up every time i charge it so
maybe a replacement
martin derbyshire you're on the line
would you be able to just make a note of
that
thank you welcome to the class how are
you today
i'm not bad thank you yourself yeah i'm
fine thank you
and lovely i've changed your name on the
screen and you're all checked in
thank you
[Music]
hello counselor powell how are you today
[Music]
wonderful are you able just to switch on
your camera just so that we know that
it's working fine
wonderful that's great thank you
take
hello counselor huckabee can you hear me
how are you counselor huckabee can you
hear me
thank you chair the feed is now alive
you're welcome to start
welcome councillors to this meeting of
council
this is a public meeting being streamed
live to you
to youtube and via the council's website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the minutes
i have been advised that the live stream
is now up and running
if for any reason the public can no
longer hear or see the meeting over the
live
livestream
we will adjourn until the connection has
been re-established
can i ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for the meeting
and to confirm the members and officers
present
this meeting is being recorded thank you
chair you have just heard a little
announcement over there to say that this
meeting is being recorded
um so this is just a reminder for all
remote attendees with us today to keep
your
cameras turned off for the duration of
the meeting and your microphone is muted
this is to enable the chair to be able
to see clearly those who are indicating
to speak
when you do wish to indicate to speak
please turn on your camera
and remain muted until you're invited to
speak
by the chair you can also use the chat
function
which will be picked up and communicated
to the chair throughout the meeting
voting during this meeting will mainly
be undertaken
by use of zoom polls which we've used uh
previously these will be issued to you
at the appropriate time
if you have any issues in using this
poll to
to submit your vote please make it known
to the meeting
and where required the team will be
asked to commence a vote by other
methods
such as a show of hands or by a roll
call
if you're having any technical issues
please contact me via the chat function
or by calling me direct i believe that
everybody should have my phone number
and phone numbers of the team members to
support you during this meeting
chair prior to the meeting i've checked
all those people who are in attendance
to ensure they can all see here and be
heard
um so in attendance today we have
remotely councillors armitage barker
barry berkin bone kevin
bone pat patricia clough
cooper cornwall
emmons angelique foster mark foster
fennell gomezrini all
hancock hill homes huckabee
hunt hutchinson jones
kenyon kerry lewis
liggett lilly
pickering howell rennick
reader row rouse ruff
shipman stone tate
welton whitehead windley
brian wright and p wright and attendance
in the chamber
we have uh the leader of the council
alex dale
and deputy leader charlotte cupid the
chair of the council yourself council
uh pat ancliff and the vice chair
councilman martin pacquiao mpe
also in the chamber is councillor peter
elliott and supporting the chair today
is the director of environmental
enforcement karen hansen
um also in the meeting room you have
officers supporting the meeting
you've got sarah stoneborough who is the
monitoring officer jane dethick who's
the section 151 officer
lee hicken who's the head of paid
service and
myself i'm the governor's manager i'll
be facilitating this meeting
and members of my team are on the line
also to support
thank you chair thank you
do we have any apologies for abstinence
there's no parts
yeah apologies um submissions to this
meeting our counselor mo potts and
councillor tracy reeder
nikki i thought you you read tracy's
name out at the beginning but
obviously she's for apologizing i heard
you say reader once
that's correct pastor barker um council
tracy reader has submitted her apologies
well excuse me can i just say you forgot
to mention my name nichola
my apologies councillor ridgeway
and i also recorded apologies from
councillor parking
[Music]
i think somebody just mentioned the name
but i can't hear what the tier is saying
uh could could you do something in
regards to
the microphone the sound i can't hear it
[Music]
declarations of interest members who
have interest
should have declared them to the
governance manager in advance of the
meeting
however i will ask again can members
please indicate if they have any
interest to declare
no interests were declared to me before
the meeting
minutes of the last meeting can we
approve the minutes of the last meeting
as a true and accurate record
may have a second day
happy two moon and chair country
for um approving the minutes to approve
as a credit record
and for the chair to sign the minutes of
council for the meeting on the 13th of
july
i'm just waiting for the members to
issue their votes
and then i'll pop it up on the screen
for you chair
nikki um there's a few people on chat
saying that having problems listening
and hearing what's going on in the
chamber
okay if we don't use the microphones is
that better
for you all to hear us
well i can hear you but councillor lewis
and councillor lilly are having problems
hearing
they're in order to make sure that all
the members are able to hear
those members that are having problems
um hearing would you mind just turning
on your cameras for a moment
and we will just resolve that
um counselor lily if um if
counselor dale was to speak just then as
he did without the microphones was that
easier for you to hear
vicki it's karen hanson here a message
to say that it might be better for us
not to use the microphones in the
council chamber so we're going to try
that can you let us know if you can hear
me okay
i can hear you loud and clear um
counselor you are having an issue here
in the chair is that still the case um i
think council lily may be having some
technical issues i'll arrange for a
technician to give him a call to to make
sure that that is resolved
um
it's not very good but it's better from
my perspective
thank you we'll speak clearer and louder
can't do that can't make out what
they're saying
uh counselor lily i'll try and assist by
putting up some captions on the screen
so if you'd like to turn up your
captioning
i'll um and i'll get a technician to
call you and we'll try to resolve it
chair i've issued the poll um we've had
voting
for against an abstain for the minute so
i'm just going to share those results on
your screen
and you'll see that 100 of members voted
for that's 38 votes
for the minutes which means that that is
carried
thank you
we're going to item four
[Music]
on sunday it's announcements and on
sunday the 30th of august
the vice chair of the council
and i greeted walkers at the end of the
5.3
miles walk to the commemorative gay
rights pioneer edward carpenter
who lived in milthorpe for over 40 years
from the 1890s thank you to councillor
okabe
for joining us on this occasion as the
ward member
welcome for all those who participated
and raising money for the derbyshire
lgbt
center in chesterfield as well as an
awareness of edward carpenter
i'd also thank colleagues in the absence
of north
derbyshire's council commemoration i was
pleased to invite
to be invited by only more side of
walton parish council to attack
ghostly a distance commemorate
for dj day at their war memorial on the
15th of august
this ensured the marking of the end of
the second world war
and a remembering of those who fought in
the far east
public participation i can confirm that
no public questions
have been submitted so we shall move on
to the next
item transformation program update
may 2019 to may 2 2020
and i now invite councillor kenyon to
present the transformation
program update report thank you
yes thank you chair can everybody hear
me
okay the transformation program was
started with the aims of transforming
how we go down to our business
uh looking for cost savings service
improvements
and also emissions reductions
and the transformation it's not just
about saving money it's about
flexibility and being able to adapt
and this flexibility was recently put
through a massive test
when kovid hit i think we can all be
proud of how the whole
organization responded and i would like
to thank all our officers for how
they've thrown themselves into
transformation
and i strongly believe that the culture
that we have
was a significant contributor to why
this council
is such a great job for our residents
and continues to do that job
i won't cover climate change here as
that's in the next report and the
the two reports overlap so financially
we have a goal of saving two million
pounds from 2018 to 2022
and we're on track to achieve that with
uh six to nine projects and climbing
and most of those projects will continue
delivering savings year on year long
into the future
our digital transformations led to a new
website which is ranked as one of the
the best in the country it's been up to
number three i think at one point
and over the year we've also added over
60 sales new self-service options
allowing residents to report issues 24 7
while at the same time letting our
contact centre focus on the the less
digitally aware
and through that time our complaints
have also fallen
to support agile working we've invested
in a variety
of digital technologies and because of
that we were well placed when
kovid hit and it was a massive test of
rit systems in particular
and while they were niggles it was a
huge testament to how well prepared
those systems were another key aspect of
transformation programs developing our
staff
and the leadership academy that's part
of the program has 12 staff
working through it now and there are
further 20 staff enrolled
on accredited leadership training
programs
and the academy also includes a change
makers program
change makers sorry select office has
developed five years for business
improvements and
efficiency improvements for the council
so going
forward this work will continue and
we'll have a strong focus
especially in the year coming on
focusing on supporting new opportunities
that working from home brings
and that will give us huge carbon
savings through reduced commuting and
office use
uh use financial savings quality of life
improvements for employees
and greater flexibility for how
residents can access
our services so that'll be a key for
focus for the next 12 months
thank you
i don't know chair if we need to i don't
think we need to vote on this it's just
to note the report isn't it
thank you chair i'm uh very happy to
second
uh the emotion that we note this report
and also to echo uh the comments of
councillor kenyon
uh in thanking staff and members for
their engagement with the transformation
agenda
um it really is heartening to see ideas
coming from
uh from all all sort of tears of this
organization
and feeding into how we can really
transform the organization
uh to be more efficient and effective
and all the things that council is kevin
said so i'm very happy to
share uh so we're very happy to uh
second this motion chair thank you
more comments thank you counselor
thank you chair am i all right come on
yes
do i do we have to rate for a red line
or anything
again i'd like to thank councillor
kenyon for that report and also
thank all the officers for uh for the
work during the
the coving which ain't going away yet
i'm sure we
we know that um and also for all the the
officers that put together this
uh this uh document
well-presented document i think and i'll
accept or we accept that there's there's
some progress has been made and
and over the last year but i can't help
thinking
that it's it's i think it's a little bit
light
uh on how we get the the two million
pound
uh and and let's just say i'll be
monitoring or we'll be monitoring the uh
the identified projects and initiatives
with interests going forward uh it's
the they still seem a bit a bit lacking
in detail i think then
with regards to digital transformation
again there's three pages of information
all looks impressive and and i accept or
we'd accept that
that we acknowledge that that's the way
forward how we need to think
but we've got to be careful that we
don't disenfranchise disenfranchise some
sections of our community when we're
doing that
like closing our area out in offices and
stuff like that
well i'd also say the report's also a
bit light on the effects of uh
colby 19 and and now we're going to
tackle that going forward because
there's still a big issue with our town
which is costing us and
and everything else like that and
finally i just i notice on page three
there's a reference to
uh vision derbyshire and
which i believe and i have i've only
just sort of
got involved with this is that it's a
submission from
all the councils in derbyshire to to
work together
more collaboratively to try and keep the
duty as a local government
however i've also noticed this weekend
that there's a there's a paper going to
cabinet at the county council
at full council at the county council
on wednesday which as i quote will
mandate
officers within the council to prepare
an alternative route for devolution
and the development of a case for a
single unitary
for derbyshire this would ultimately
result in getting rid of
districts and worry councils
and like ours and i think i would and
the people of darvish in north east
irish who would like to know
where does councillor dale loyalties lie
willie when it pushed constitutional
vote to abolish a council that he's
leader of
or will he fight against the unitary
proposal and defend the existence of
this council
and i think it's important he's just
said how he's working to be more
efficient more this and that
but ultimately it could be on a lead
authority
that's trying to get rid of that that
very same
council thank you
thank you council barker
any further comments
i'm happy to respond come today
thank you uh thank you uh councillor
barker for those questions
it's very kind of you to uh continue to
monitor and observe the deficit that you
left this
administration with uh following your uh
your previous administration
with regards to division derbyshire
we've been absolutely clear that we have
committed division derbyshire and
achieving
uh that goal that's the best way i can
see
of of sustaining a future for this
organization
if we don't engage seriously envision
derbyshire and put that forward
as a model um there are many forces that
we clearly can't control one is
uh how the government wishes to take
forward the evolution and
local government reform and the other is
what councils around us will do and we
know that darby city
has already put forward a proposal to
split the county
um and therefore i think it is necessary
that we that the county council puts
forward vision derbyshire
but also considers considers alternative
options and it's necessary for this
council to do the same
as well which we will be doing
i refer the comments
[Music]
yes thank you chair um yes the the
concerns about achieving the two million
i'm very comfortable because we're
um this year we've got almost half a
million pounds from the
line by line budget review which is a
whole host of small
transformations essentially um and the
cumulative effect we should be well past
the two million
i share your concern about
disenfranchising
people who aren't using digital channels
but the best way we can do that is to
free up
time for example in the contact center
by
making sure that people who are willing
to use digital channels can do so so
i share your concern and we'll keep an
eye on that myself as
well obviously um recovery 19
when that affects every part of the
council it's not particularly
just for transformation or climate
change will come on to
but what i would say is one of the best
things we could do
to address that is continue developing
the ability to work remotely
um in a whole variety of ways and
working from home as part of that
that it applies for residents not having
to come into the council
site visits that planning committees
might make there's a whole host of
digital ways of addressing that which is
what the transformation program we'll be
looking at thank you
council lewis did you wish to say
something
uh thank you uh chairman just to uh
reassure
uh councillor barker that uh the county
council is fully committed to the vision
derbyshire piece of work
and i'm very pleased that uh he and his
group are bringing themselves up to
speed
um on the on the the purpose and the
reasoning behind
vision derbyshire but uh just to sort of
reiterate what uh councillor dale um has
also
just said it is important that we have a
um a backup plan in the back pocket just
in case that
is not acceptable and
and also as a as a as a key defense
uh should uh derby city try to expand
expand its borders
and uh and take up potentially up to
half of the county with it so
um whatever happens there that means
then that
whatever is in existence now will be
swept away even here in the north of the
county
so it is important that we have a a
backup plan
um for that reason thank you chairman
thank you we'll now move to the vote
can the governor's manager please lead
us in the vote
um yes of course chair i just wanted to
let you know before i issue the the vote
that uh two members have uh joined us um
since um the meeting started councillor
dayton and councillor morley are now in
the meeting room
um and just a reminder for members if
you could possibly keep your cameras off
when you're not indicating you wish to
speak this does help the chairman to
identify who wishes to speak
um yeah i'm just issuing the poll for
you now
thank you
can i just point out that those in the
chamber don't get the poll
how do we go
chair if you would like to lead a vote
by hands
in the chamber
i think that's not appropriate if i'm a
chair because then
everyone else has got the um ability to
balance secretly and ours isn't i don't
think that's an appropriate way of
dealing with this
chair you have a number of options for
voting um i can continue to issue polls
for the members voting remotely or um
if you would like for us to we can
commence um um
voting by roll call or by show of hands
council angelique foster
yes thank you i just wanted to i'm not
sure if it's a point of order
but these reports usually don't require
a secret vote
uh the fact that we're voting by way of
poll is purely due to the
the technicalities of having meetings
via zoom
but i don't quite um understand why we
would require a private secret vote on
a report which would normally be done by
a show of hands in this chamber could we
have conver
confirmation yeah that's not a point of
order
that's implying that i'm just referring
to as a secret vote
you can't tell me council foster who
else has voted in what way
neither can we but you would know how we
vote on anything
not just on this it's the principle
and my apology the question was to the
officer
i just wanted clarification on how we
were going to proceed
uh as as of now for those votes
chairman
german mayor come in sarah sternberg
monitoring officer
i think the governance manager has
outlined what you can do
you can either carry on with the poll
and do a semi-secret vote in the chamber
so that it's known to the chairman but
not to others or you can
go to a full poll on screen where we'd
have to look at every single person's
vote
right
as well
[Music]
is you can either have the existing
poles on the screen or you can go to a
um previous meetings
and go through each
[Music]
can you
the chair would like to do the old uh
way of voting please with the hands up
on the screen
please thank you okay
um chair on that basis then if you would
like
um a show of hands vote for uh the
transformation um program item i will
end the polling
and we will not reissue that poll
um and then if you would like to lead
from the chamber
a show of hands we can request that all
members turn on their cameras at this
point
and you can leave the vote and we will
do a count for you
okay thank you
[Music]
just checking that all members are happy
to turn on their cameras to do this as
we won't be able to see your vote
if um if your camera isn't on i'm just
sending a few prompts to members
to ask them to start their videos
chat i have all the videos that should
now be on
thank you thank you
[Music]
me
chair i can count 33 votes that are
clearly shown as four
two votes in the council chamber
those against
i can see one vote clearly marked
against
on this vote
any extension
i can see two abstentions chair
so that voters carry chair
thank you
um
97 climate change at dave
can i now invite council of kenyan to
present the climate change update report
well after the last excitement i'm
afraid to do so now
so thank you chair um yes there's a lot
of detail in the attached report
but again in summary it represents a lot
of hard work by
officers right across the council and
the commitment of this council to
reducing our impact
on our environment i'll just mention
some key points
and adapting to kobe has reduced our
emissions by over 100 tons this year
um obviously digital transformation is
about
supporting that so that we can keep
those gains for future years or as many
of them as possible
we've got new boilers in mill lane
that's uh saving 30 tons a year in
emissions
or wood if we were um not in the cobia
situation anyway
we've completed the first phase of the
ekkington pool efficiency work that's a
new insulated roof
that'll save um estimates to another 30
tons
and there are a myriad of smaller
projects such as
battery chainsaws which reduce papers by
79
and things like fitting led lighting in
communal areas of our flats
and we've also continued investing in
our council housing
in particular with external wall
insulation
and roof insulation on some of the most
inefficient housing stock that we've got
we've helped hundreds of residents
access funding to improve their homes
efficiency and in the wider community
northeast derbyshire is now achieving a
recycling rate of 47
that compares to a national average of
43.5
so an example of what our residents are
doing so for the next 12 months just a
quick flavor
and it's vital that we achieve the
biggest reductions for the resources
that we have available
so you'll hear me refer a lot to fabric
first
this is the principle of prioritizing
passive improvements
that will reduce energy consumption for
all the remaining decades
the building will be in use i know it
sounds mundane
but the reality is it's many times more
effective than
an electric bin lorries or something
sexy like that
so we'll continue to invest in our
facilities we've got plans for a new
leisure centre in clay cross
uh we've got further efficiency
improvements planned at eckington
and dronfield leisure centres and also
our other buildings are
or undergoing a review at the moment to
look for other opportunities
we're finding we've got facilities that
don't even have cavity wall insulation
at the moment which is amazing to me in
2020
we're also investigating several
district heating solutions
including one from old coal mines and
that would be really nice because it
would complete the reformation
of our dirty sort of coal energy past
due to a clean geothermal supply
something particularly interesting
and we'll continue to invest our own
funds
in improving council housing again
focusing on insulation
and energy efficiency and we've also
just applied for
his 2.3 million pounds of uh grant
funding
to improve inflation on uh council
housing
and finally just to say we of course
it's uh it's not just northeast we all
need to work together
resident business
time yeah finally we just need to work
together it's residents businesses
i can't hear what's being said and wait
is that time
i i will uh propose the uh we accept the
report
thank you councillor kenya is there a
second day
yesterday
[Music]
and also to thank uh members and staff
for their engagement with this engender
thank you very much you
did you wish did you say something
because all right
can i can i comment j i don't if you can
see me
house parker thank you
uh again i welcome this report and and
thanks
uh council kenyan for this and again i'd
thank the officers and and all the work
that's
gone into it i think it's fair to say
all them figures are pointing it right
direction and uh it's looking good
uh they're not same thing we shouldn't
be complacent i don't think because
i think we need to recognize some of
these figures are based on
on the increase in home working and less
travel and all this sort of stuff
and again um in relation to that
i just like reassurances that the
council is looking at
improving its own working policy and
taking into account the new normal
as they call it uh i don't know why i'm
doing that nobody can see me
and the possible increase in on working
uh going forward because
let's not forget that that while our
energy consumptions might be going down
the
uh people are staying at home and
they've got use their own
so uh there's issues around that didn't
they
and i'd also like to comment on the way
that rikon's doing and
i'd like to take a a bit of personal
uh credit for that and and obviously the
future the past administration because
that external war insulation uh
while it's good for re reducing carbon
emissions
it also saves people tenants customers
whatever we like to call them
a lot of money because uh obviously
we've had experience of that in
in wingfield and it's a it's a really
positive thing so the more we can
roll that out the better for everybody
concerned
so really it's it's uh keep up the work
on that
thank you
thank you thank you councillor gomez
okay
thank you chair and uh thanks to
councillor kenyon for the report um
what i would like to see uh this council
do more is actually speak to the public
about this
these climate um change
initiatives that we're trying to bring
in because i think it's all well and
good as the council is talking to each
other and
coming up with things that we feel the
public wants or are going to be able to
do
but ultimately it's the public we need
to get on side they need to be buying
into the council's climate change plan
um and whilst an electric
um what do you call it a litter um
machine might not necessarily
be the most efficient use of resources
it's certainly something that we need to
do because one of the biggest problems
with badminton is getting
emissions out of the system that will be
the oddest
you know five percent of carbon
emissions that this council will have to
deal with
so we need to be getting people buying
into the plan
and and not just talking down to people
and expecting them to um
buy in so i do i would like to see
councillor king and talk to the public
more
get you know some experts opinions in
from from the public
businesses that we've got around us and
use that to develop the plan
into the future thank you
thank you council kenyan do you wish to
use your right to reply
um oh yes thank you um first
councilor barker i completely agree we
can't be complacent and some of the
officers will tell you
i've been asking them some very hard
questions about what our target should
be going forwards
because um it's a very difficult task
that the entire planet faces really
and we all have to play our part and i
also agree it's very nice that sometimes
doing this work is a win-win scenario
for residents and that's uh
just makes one of the nicer things about
working on climate change
for councillor councillor shipman uh yes
i
i completely agree the public needs to
be heavily involved in this
i think it was a few council meetings
ago there was question about
a citizen's assembly and
that will be one one way of doing that
and the
county council are taking the lead on
that uh but i do think we have to
be very careful about what our
priorities are
because it really is boring mundane
stuff
that will give us the biggest wins and
we
you know we only have a finite amount of
money to play with we can't
whack the police office pre-set up some
huge amount
to fund things that will tackle that
last five percent
when we haven't tackled the first 95 so
it's a prioritization i take your point
that we need to do all of those things
at some point um and it's just down to
choosing the priorities to be as
effective as they can be
thank you thank you
thank you yeah
[Music]
sorry thank you cheer uh just a quick
question for council kenyan we were
promised um
about nine months ago a climate change
pack which would be distributed to
parish councils
etc um i've not seen that yet i've been
kept
being asked questions about that can you
tell me where we are with actually
getting that out into the parishes
absolutely yes that was good to be in
the the last 10 seconds where
i'm not sure if i actually ran out of
time or if it was a warning that i got a
one minute warning i couldn't tell but
uh the pack was circulated or
three months ago now it was also
circulated to every parish in derbyshire
as it turns out because i
i was part of um a team of it was a
climate conference and
i sent it to the facilitators now so
it's gone very widely
um i'll check why you haven't received
it or maybe it would have been sent to
your clerk actually
and it is a key thing that we've got to
work together on and it's a parish and
town level
if you um if your class hasn't received
that pack
then um she should do but i would
encourage every one of you you're
probably nearly all parish councillors
please be raising these things at your
own parish councils
because a very local level you've got
things you can do directly
but you've also got things that you can
encourage your residents to do
and for example communicating about this
insulation scheme might be a thing at
the moment to get into your newsletters
and also i'm sure nearly everybody here
will be involved in
other organizations of various kinds and
again
take the opportunities to nudge any
organization you're part of just nudge
them on climate change and just keep on
essentially nagging people i suppose in
a nice way about it
so thank you
thank you we'll now move to the boat
thank you um yeah now i'll just say i
just wanted to say that yes it was
distributed to parish councillors and
there was some really good stuff in
there and i really appreciated it being
sent to me
um there were some things that i wanted
to suggest uh
to changes and i sent them to the the
relevant people
but on the whole there was a really good
starting point
so thank you
thank you we'll now move to the vote
can the governor's manager please lead
us in the vote
thank you chair um is it your wish that
i do this by a show of hands
yes on that basis then may i ask for all
members
with uh to turn on your cameras
and when the chairman will leave the
vote just say for against
abstain i'm asking you to raise your
hand if you could put it clearly near to
your face like this then we'll be able
to see
on your screens um chat i'm just going
to
send a few prompts members to ask them
to start videos
and when all are on i'll let you know
to lead the vote
chair all of the member videos are now
on if you would like to leave the vote
for against abstain
[Music]
okay
that's 44. sure
in the council chamber
those are gates
[Music]
yeah there are no votes against online
there is one member indicating they wish
to abstain from this vote
thank you
chair with the first 44 votes for that
that
would be carried
thank you
can i confirm that we have three
questions submitted under procedure
9-2 the first question is from counselor
nigel barker
directed to counselor alex bale leader
of the council
[Music]
i just just before i asked my question
i'd just like to make the point and
and i know i've had an email today alex
from uh
from your regarding the covered uh the
viper meetings
but i did feel that uh that we did feel
as though we're going back to this
adversarial sort of politics uh and
answer all these questions and motions
to today's meeting
i did request a couple i've sent a
couple of uh emails sort of trying to
make some sort of dialogue but
i i accept that you've you've made the
effort today so we're
so well done on that and re-establishing
the biofue meeting
uh just just for my question as it's
written there like can you uh
update us on on the call are the culvert
crisis impacted on the uh
financial position of the council and
wriggles
especially with reference to the capital
programme cheers
thank you ken for barca for the question
just just in relation to
um viper meetings and and and the
issue per se i'm sorry if you've
contacted me and i haven't uh responded
that i'm aware you wrote to me about the
area housing offices
um i'm not aware of any other emails so
i apologize if that's been missed
on the wider point though obviously um
you know august has been a period of
recess for most councillors that have
most people have been away
it was always our intention to re-engage
with the viper meetings
uh and particularly now seems like an
appropriate time
uh with all the preparations for winter
winter planning and winter resilience so
we will proceed with that meeting
soon and hopefully we can uh continue to
meet on that basis i have no
desire to have any uh sort of
adversarial politics
on that issue at all in relation to the
question the pandemic is inevitably
having a detrimental
impact on the current year's budget and
cash flow
with the main concern obviously being
the lost income from fees and charges
it's also worth reiterating that the
kobe crisis
and its impact on the council is ongoing
um and so the information i'm going to
provide now is obviously
only deals with what we know at this at
this moment in time
and the council has received grant from
government totaling 1.2 million
which i'm sure you will agree is hugely
welcome
in addition the government's income
compensation scheme for lost fees and
charges
will help considerably in towards
covering the
forecast income losses we haven't yet
yet got the precise detail of that
scheme
but officers suggest that it's likely to
be in the region of 800
000 pounds income losses of 1.7 million
are currently predicted mainly because
of the closure of our ledger centres
and the suspension of other services
such as mot testing during lockdown
and whilst reopening will allow us to
begin to generate income again
social distancing restrictions will
limit capacity considerably
so income is not expected to return to
pre-lockdown levels
for some time yet at the start of the
national lockdown budget
controls were quickly put in place as
you're aware from the previous
viper meetings to limit expenditure to
essential items only
during this time including pausing of
the capital programmes
this was largely to protect the cash
flow position including during the
period of lockdown
when only limited works could be carried
out carried out due to the
uh national restrictions in place both
programs were imposed as soon as
practicable
with work on the housing capital program
commencing once again in may
since may uh wriglet homes have really
wrapped up
on the external major works programmes
and
ensure that all in-house teams are being
fully utilized wherever possible
badges have been put in place to ensure
the organization is compliant with the
new construction
health and industry health and safety
guidance to ensure that staff can work
safely and that customers are protected
it's anticipated that the majority of
the housing capital program will be
delivered during the financial year
any exceptions to this will be reported
in the half-year budget review
and the program reprofiled at that time
the cash flow position has remained
relatively static
throughout this period as a result of
these measures and deferred payments to
the government for business rates
better than forecast collection rates
for council tax business rates
and rents have also assisted so at the
end of august council tax
was down by just 1.5 percent on last
year
business rates were down by just four
percent both
much higher than our initial forecasts
have suggested
rental income is just 1.4 lower than the
same period last year
and was actually higher than the target
during lockdown
as a result of some of the proactive
welfare calls
that we made to tenants uh the council
and written homes will continue to
support
people and help and support anyone in
financial difficulty
following the government guidance in
relation to arrears actions
we are however very aware that this is a
evolving position
that can change quickly the end of the
furlough scheme next month
is likely to have an impact so we will
continue to closely monitor this
position over the coming months
on a positive note planning fees and
industrial unit rents have remained at
pre-pandemic levels throughout
as we now start to enter the recovery
phase
and many of our services can begin to
operate in some capacity again
our main priority is to provide as far
as possible some stability
within the budget for the rest of this
financial year and to facilitate this
the revised budget process is already
under way of council
written homes financial position is
strong enabling full housing services to
be provided to customers
with budgets currently being reviewed to
ensure the postcoded
business recovery plan can be delivered
thank you very much
thank you councillor barker do you have
a supplementary question
you'd like to ask well thank you thanks
counselor dale that's
very comprehensive like i fully expected
that you know the the the
revenue budgets are going to be very
strange i'd imagine because
like you say the income stopped and
everything else it were more around the
capital
program and and i accept i've seen in
the cabinet papers that
you're cautiously releasing uh
restrictions
uh on the cabinet and we're just trying
to get some reassurances that finger
back on track really a little bit that
we're starting to spend
some of that capital budget i understand
the revenue budgets
nobody knows really what are we going
forward we still don't
that's my phone right now er
er where were and with that in mind and
i know i'm being particular at this bit
but
uh i just like some reassurances
and the people in north wingfield about
the uh the development of whiteley's
avenue and how long because that's been
paused for a while now
and people are asking me what's
happening basically with that
and and when will that be in the park
line
and have you got a a timeline for that
cheers
thank you uh councillor barker for the
supplementary um
the uh the situation you're right
obviously
um due to cash flow issues the the
council did have to
be cautious with the capital budget but
i do accept the point and i would agree
that actually fundamental to our
recovery is that
the fact that the council does spend
that capital budget because that is
helpful to the
to the local economy and with regard to
whiteley's
avenue um we're as keen as you are
to see some progress on that the
delivery options for the scheme are
being considered
uh by the council and we're hoping to
consult with local residents
in october or preparations are being
made
on that basis in line with the code with
90 restrictions
and following the outcome of both items
or a revised delivery program
uh will be developed for the project
with a view
to being on site in late spring of next
year so
i appreciate it's disappointing that
we've had that pause with that project
but we are
very much hoping to uh to get started
and get going as soon as we possibly can
thank you thank you thank you
sorry chair um you disappeared all
together i couldn't hear anything that
came out the council chamber
uh i assume you're asking for my
question so i'll put it forward um
before i actually put the question
to the leader i'd like to say that
whilst we're aware that
a post was placed on facebook stating
that there'd be a two-minute silence at
11 o'clock on the day of vj day
um and a lone piper did play a lament on
twitter this
as far as we're concerned is very
disappointing given that we hold a
bronze and silver award given to us by
the supporters of the armed forces
and the fact that the council has two
civic cadets
so can the leader summarize what the
district did to commemorate vijay day
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor barry for your question
as you may be aware the council had
originally intended to host at least one
community event to commemorate b.j in
addition to the two we have planned in
clay cross
and killer marsh earlier in the year for
be day
when the national be day programme of
events was cancelled by the queen's
pageant master
due to code 19 we haven't hoped to
reschedule these events to the 15th of
august
in the weeks preceding the 15th of
august the national guidance on kobit 19
was that large-scale outdoors gatherings
should be avoided wherever possible
the queen's pageant master had also
advised against holding
large events for uh bj day and instead
only uh
suggested or advised three limited
activities
which namely were pipers at 5 47 a.m
buglers at 11 a.m or 8 18 p.m
and town cryos at 11 05 a.m
due to the continued uncertainty
surrounding cohort 19 and the challenges
in
forward planning such an event as well
as the continued risk to public health
particularly for those in vulnerable
categories officers took the decision
not to host the community events
the three activities suggested by the
queen's pageant master
were also explored by officers but for
various reasons were not considered
practical
the authority did suppose his uh support
for the vj day commemorations and as the
chair has said
by a very kind invitation holly moore
side and walton parish council
the chair did attend an event a
commemorative event there
i'm sure you will like me be
disappointed that the council
did not host an event itself to
commemorate vj day
and i am very sorry that that is the
case i recognize that this is a really
historic
important commemoration and i
wholeheartedly apologize if you or
anyone else feel the council didn't do
enough
uh to recognize it as such um
but what i would say is that should the
council should the coded restrictions
allow
uh next year it is our intention to host
a 1940s themed festival events and
activities
to ensure that both ve day and bj day
and the huge sacrifices of our armed
forces can be commemorated
in the way that they deserve to have
been this year
thank you thank you
councillor barry have you got a
supplementary question you'd like to ask
uh yeah i think um i am still very
disappointed councillor dale
over the fact that you know there were
some areas and some birds in some
districts that did
continue to do some form of
commemoration for this important and
historic day
you know the people the the soldiers
that were out there were already known
as the forgotten warriors
you know the least we could have done as
a district council was to acknowledge
them
some of those people that lost their
lives supporting us and giving us a
better world were from our district
so i am really disappointed in the fact
that northeast arms you couldn't see
themselves put on
some form of event to commemorate them
um and you know i'd like to see and ask
the council
at the leader again as to why the chair
and vice chair were not supported by
the armed officers champion in putting
something together
you know we've we've just got these
awards and we've done nothing so can
they can the leader tell me why they
didn't feel it's important enough
to do something about these forgotten
warriors just to say we're disappointed
isn't
enough i'm afraid thank you
councilman you appreciate it was um
around the time the planning for this
event would have been taking place was
around the time that i took over as
leader of the council
and it's by no means an excuse but there
was a lot going on
uh and i'm afraid i wasn't aware that
the decision had been taken
um to uh to to not proceed with an event
had i
been aware had it been brought to my
intention i certainly would have
encouraged a very small commemorative
event in line with the code with 19
restrictions
all i can do is recognize what you're
saying
and and the fact that this event is
extremely important to many people
across our district particularly those
who were affected by the war directly
and and i can very much
um pledge and commit the subject to the
code 19
regulations next year we very much hope
to run a proper event
and give those at those two days that
the the
the commemoration and the the
the um the the recognition that they
deserve
thank you unfortunately we
are running out of time um we only have
five minutes left for the last
question and the third question is from
councillor maggie jones directed
to councillor alex dale leader of the
council
councilor jones
can you hear me now
thank you wherever your question
counselor jones tom councillor dale
uh food drop-offs medical drop-offs have
ceased
just at a point where more people are
out of work and unable to feed
themselves and their families
the food parcels and delivery of
medicine
that the council put together helped a
great many people
and to stop it now when numbers of
corvette 19 cases
on the are on the rise
in this area seems
illogical can the leader enlighten
as to why this has happened
and the reasoning behind it please
counselor dale thank you chair and thank
you council james for your question
and i want to start by clarifying that
during the lockdown period in the code
19 pandemic there have been two separate
schemes
to provide food and other essential
items for vulnerable residents
firstly as you'll know the government
introduced a shielding scheme
for the clinically extremely vulnerable
this included the provision of food
boxes
which were provided by central
government when the assistance of
davashi county council
at northeast avenue district council and
rigonald homes were acquired
this service ceased on the 31st of july
following a decision by central
government
that the shielding scheme was no longer
required due to the reduction in cases
all those who were on the government
shielded list received information
to support them with the transition this
included details of slots for home
deliveries
with local supermarkets this list is
being maintained so that it's up to date
should it be required again in the
future
in addition to the government shielded
scheme as you all know
the council and richmond homes have
worked together to ensure that all
residents can urgently access support
when needed
up to last week the council had received
a total of 6772 contacts
for support during the code 19 pandemic
this has been reducing slowly and we've
received only one such request
since the 30th of july specifically with
regard to food deliveries the council
has undertaken
37 food shops for those with specific
food requirements due to medical
collisions
and made a total of 61 food box
deliveries
throughout the lockdown period in
addition rigonald homes provided around
11 food boxes per week
during the peak time in april with a
steady decline in requests seen after
then
only two boxes were requested in july
support was also provided to local food
banks with regular food collections made
by rippled homes
to ensure the ongoing supply of
essential items were available
i want to be absolutely clear with you
councillor jones
that there has been no decision to cease
this support nor the emergency delivery
of food parcels from the council and
wriggled
it is simply the case that demand has
significantly reduced
and we have not received any further
requests for food parcels
in recent weeks i can assure you that
any new
request that would come in from a
vulnerable person
we would working with partners of course
support those people in any way that we
can
and that will remain the case thank you
chair
thank you councillor john do you have a
supplementary question
it's good to hear that but
we'll i'm so concerned that things are
going to escalate
we're not at the bottom of this we are
actually going to be going up more
people
are going to have problems we've already
got
people on the furlough scheme that's
going to end in october
that's going to put a lot of people in
real financial difficulties especially
if firms they're employed by are unable
to keep them on just because they're no
longer viable
um the food drops in their
own in themselves were more than just
about delivering
food it was also medication
and it was also the opportunity to offer
support to people
people who are often frightened and
lonely and i'd like that to continue
i think that we were doing a really good
job
and maybe it's um some of it's to do
with central government but we
have some responsibility for the people
in our area
and i'd like us to continue to give them
the support that they deserve
and given the possibility of a second
wave of
coughing 19 will the leader consider
reinstating the invaluable drop-offs
if it's at all possible thank you
counselor thank you uh councillor jones
for the supplementary
question um as i said earlier in the
exchange with councillor barca we are
intending to have a viper meeting
shortly which is considering that very
issue of the potential of a second wave
and i can absolutely assure you that if
we
um if we do end up in a similar
challenging situation as we found
ourselves in earlier
this year we stand very much ready
to support our residents uh in any way
that we that we possibly can
and i'm sure that um obviously depending
on the circumstances
uh we can very much consider the issue
of food
parcels and uh food deliveries emergency
food deliveries
if necessary what i would say though is
that we do have to try and balance
uh continuing our day-to-day services
with emergency support
and judging by the the uh
what the national restrictions uh
suggest uh we can and can't do at the
time
and uh and also what the
r rate is and how many cases there are
we do need to sort of balance that
emergency support to residents which is
absolutely fundamental and i don't
disagree with you
with also continuing to provide the
day-to-day services that our
our residents rightly expect from us
thank you chair thank you councillor
dale that concludes today's questions we
will now move on to the next item of the
agenda
in accordance with the council procedure
rule 10 i can confirm that there are
four motions to consider
i now invite councillor david hancock to
move
motion a on the agenda council anne carl
thank you chair um the motion is a
simple one i'm not going to read through
it
um but it's a recurring issue that we
have with all of our planning well the
vast majority of our planning
applications
the highways the responses that we get
from highways as a statutory council t
are very often non-committal um
we had an incident um
at sherland a few weeks ago with
hallfield gate lane which anyone who's
ever driven down there once knows that
that's not a viable point for junction
according to highway is no issue we've
got an appeal hearing next week for
uh for wingworth where again
they say no issue yet um several years
ago they actually declined for returning
at the same point
last year we had the uh very
embarrassing offered
county council anyway not for us
embarrassing situation where they uh
they approved the entry to a traveller
site then had to revoke it because of
course it was directly opposite to
junction to a major development
so the proposal is that we actually
contact them
as a planning authority our decisions
are based on the quality of information
that we're provided with and quite
clearly that quality is lacking
so i the the motion is a stands that the
council actually approaches them and
said we need
better from them we can't do a
legitimate job
and we're bearing the brunt for for
their
for their poor poor um reports um i
think it's also worth pointing out that
i
two years ago i was actually the
inspector's hearing for the local plan
and the representative from dcc highways
actually confessed
that they don't take into account the
cumulative impact
which they're actually required to do
under the national parliament policy
framework
so again we've already got admissions
from them um i know
colleagues have actually been at
meetings where they said exactly the
same thing
so we we need to insist that the data
that we're given is actually accurate
and we're making our decisions based on
that
thank you is there a second
i'll second that um
um yes if i could say a few words
basically i totally agree with uh
council lang [ __ ] i mean i've recently
just gone on committee and
the the the level of reports from
dcc whether intentional or not
they don't do what is required for a
planning committee
to look at and think is this going to be
a good development oh the highways issue
is fine
i can remember it might have been a year
and a half ago when
council lewis i believe held a um
an event in wingworth about the eighth
about the a61
and one of the planning engineers
actually at the time
admitted that they are reluctant to
submit comments that are
negative towards a development because
they get overturned in appeals
well if we've got a uh statutory council
t
who's who's essentially and i'm
paraphrasing are scared to
put the truth onto a bit of paper then
what sort of planning system have we
actually got
we need we need proper reports we need
them to be accurate
we need them to say as it is we need
highways reports that uh
uh that have been done recently to when
the development's been put i mean the
one that council linecott referred to uh
is it whole field played in sherland and
there's many councillors in including
council cooper it was at that uh
debate and that highway's report that we
were
being asked to make a decision on
was i think it was three years out of
date
well if that's the level of of
information we're being gifted
then it's making the the planning
committees um job
now and impossible to make an accurate
decision so i fully support what council
hancock is saying
um and i think we seriously need to
start speaking up to the developers
speaking for the consultancies to make
sure that
the information is accurate and that we
aren't just passing things on a whim
thank you jeff thank you councilman
although the help
can
i've also been wanting to say something
in all time
who's that mikey who is it is it me
i i'd just like i'm i'm going to move
an amendment and and so i want to try
and get in first so what
uh we're not we're not going over grand
twice lot really
i think from our group there's a lot of
sympathy with this motion we can
understand
where it's coming from and i think
anybody that sat on planning committee
readily
uh genuinely get frustrated with the
highway comments you know or no comments
when
it's obviously an emotive issue but i
also
know that the officers at the county
council are working under
uh they've got to abide by uh
government policies and and all that
sort of stuff
uh and they they obviously of uh
they could it's a desktop exercise a lot
of time
uh the volume of traffic that the width
of roads all that sort of stuff and
it's either that's suitable or it's not
which doesn't
reflect well at a planning committee so
i'd like instead
of the the the council resolves the last
one
uh is just amend that uh
and and actually refer this to a
security committee
where i think there's arguments both
sides and i think the scrutiny committee
can actually look at what the
regulations are what the highways
officers have to
work towards but i also think there's a
there's a
a communications issue about how
those decisions are related back if
you're in a
planning meeting and there's a lot of
people there that are objecting to it
and know there's a lot of traffic and
all it says is no comment
that doesn't reflect well on the on any
council to be honest
whether it's us or the county and i just
wondered if uh
possibly a community scrutiny committee
can actually get some
highways officers in to look at their
sort of roles and responsibilities and
also express
our concerns about how they communicate
their decisions
so the amendment and i don't know if you
got it nikki did you get it i don't i
did send it just to try and help
only 10 minutes before the meeting yeah
i've um i've just uh popped that i can
pop that on the screen for members um
it just means that everybody yeah go on
then i don't know if i spelled gilroy
is that correct as you'd like it
councillor barker
it's just the last bit oh you've crossed
us for consideration
well that'll do yeah i did put all the
bits in but
i've just said what those those gold
considerations are
so i don't need to wear them do i it's
just to refer it to scrutiny committee
okay
you've amended my amendment then nikki
i apologize i did that live in the
meeting i can look at your proper
amendment
it's alright it's alright that'll do
thank you councillor brian wright
thank you chair uh all israeli it's just
for clarification
and guardians uh new to me dual role i
am on
an elected member of county council and
also a member of the camp council
planning
so does this still allow me to vote on
this
just a bit of guidance from governance
you'll get it from me um you've made it
clear i don't see
any reason why the declaration should
mean you couldn't do anything other than
the state speaking vote so stay speaking
though
yeah okay thank you
thank you
can somebody say my amendment do you
think yeah
i'm just trying to do that now nigel
can i second nigel's amendment please
thank you
councillor cooper thank you chef um can
everybody hear me okay
i'm a bit squeaky but i i understand
speak both
on the original uh motion and on the
amendment
i understand the points you're making
and the concerns that
i think we all have but i don't think
this motion or the wording of it
even amended is the right way to go
about it to be fair to highways
in order to object to a proposal as
outlined in the mppf
the impact has to be and i quote
demonstrably severe
that's difficult to illustrate as we've
seen when highways has been used as a
reason for refusal in the past
contrary to dcc advice and even with
independent highways reviews which is
something that
we've been doing recently in the council
we've had significant costs awarded
against this council since
so whilst i share your frustrations i'm
not aware of any local appeal decisions
where an independent inspector has found
there to be severe and demonstrable harm
contrary to what highways has commented
or asked for
but having said that i think there are
options and as i say i understand the
concerns rates i think there's other
things we can do
for individual applications i think it's
all of our responsibility as ward
members to raise
queries or concerns on behalf of
residents when we aren't sure about the
comments or to highlight local events
and views
and ask highways to review it i've
certainly done this in my ward um most
recently with westington
but also with the audio gateway
application that you mentioned
secondly highways have always provided
technical engineering and
advice because that's what they're
statutorily bound to do
awards members can and should as i've
just said raise their own issues
and then it's over to the planning
committee ultimately to decide as a
previous planning committee member
myself at the same as yourself council
hangover i think council
you'll of course be aware that the final
decision always rests with the committee
and there are ways to improve highways
in wider infrastructure concerns and
reasons
which i think we need to help and
support planning committee members
before
so i think the summary here is that this
motion would actually hinder a problem
we're already trying to solve
the public criticism of highway officers
might make us feel good but it's not
actually going to make take any action
or do anything
as a council and as an administration
we've already been working on this by
representing residents and raising
individual cases with highways
but also for my own part as cabinet
member i've had several conversations
with officers on this topic over the
last year
indeed there was work by officers
earlier in the year before coping
in february march to engage with
highways officers
and get them to come to a future
planning committee meeting or some sort
of workshop to have a really good
discussion
discussion issues such as this and cases
and provide some advice and training
this has obviously been delayed due to
covid but planning officers have already
been working to set that back up
over the last month or so so there
should be a don't seem
similarly intended just to touch on the
cumulative impact which i think
councillor hancock you mentioned again
some of that i think lies with the
planning committee to recognize and
refuse applications as
you know they see fit but with regards
to the a61 in particular
which i think is where both of our
concerns lie and essentially where mine
do
there's quite a significant amount of
section 106 money for highways improved
and pending
because of the applications which have
already been approved and highways are
working on options
which conservatives are supporting i
think it's right to again engaged with
trying to solve that particular
pre-existing problem in that way
in a supportive way so i think both of
these that just outlined are the better
constructed and engaging approaches
with positive action so i'm going to
continue to support that work
and won't therefore be supporting this
notion with regards to the amendment
in terms of referring it to a scrutiny
committee
i think as i've just said the better way
is
for planning committee members they're
ultimately the ones who make the
decision
to have the the talk and the discussions
with highways and with highways directly
and i think that's
you know opening a dialogue with them is
the right way to do it so
i'm afraid i can't support the amendment
and i can't support a motion but i hope
you
understand the reason why thank you
[Music]
[Music]
i don't think he does
can i speak chair
thank you very much chair um i
understand where
counselor coop it's coming from but i
still
feel that this is an area that needs to
go to a scrutiny committee
um because we're not only talking about
those people that sit on the planning
committee
but the public needs to be aware of what
the um the authorities in the highways
are responsible for and how it works and
i think by doing a public scrutiny
uh meeting and getting the highways
involved in that
and giving the chance of the local
people to voice their opinions and not
just
the councillors um i think we need to be
moving that forward i know
um i certainly have concerns about how
highways
work fully understand that they're stuck
to the regulations and
and what i mean that the central
government and everything have laid out
but they don't always come forward and
make it clear the reasons as to why
they've made the decisions that they've
made
and if you're a
person from the general public sitting
in on a planning committee meeting you
wouldn't have a clue
what they're talking about so you know i
think we do need to have
a scrutiny i think it needs to be put
forward
um we can invite people into those
scrutiny committees they are a public
meeting
to a certain extent so i think we should
be looking forward to doing that
um you commented on the 106 monies and
about the a61 corridor
under the white paper the 106 money will
disappear
so you know we do need to be looking at
this and i think the
the suggestion of having a meeting with
um the
officers from the uh highways
departments an excellent idea
we did try it previously and it didn't
succeed uh
because they refused to come to the
meeting but i do feel we've got to now i
mean
the especially the south of the county
we're getting clobbered
with lots and lots of planning
applications we have a very very poor
infrastructure in relation to the road
and the highways and this isn't
something we can hang around on anymore
we've got more and more larger
developments taking place and we need to
be moving forward so i still
go with the scrutiny and think we should
be going forward with that screwed
up that motion that was put forward
um and that i second um and i you know
i think that would help us move forward
with the motion that councillor
hancock's
uh submitted earlier on uh we've got to
be proactive
not sit back we've got to be out there
and showing how we are fighting this and
highlighting to highways how they need
to be perhaps challenging
some of the regulations that are being
put forward as we move on
uh through this process of house
building and especially with the fact
that the white paper
is going to make a mockery of a lot of
it thank you
thank you counselor thank you cher um
i would just say that i um share some of
the sentiments behind this man
the highways um haven't done enough
to to to put a blocker in the way of
that development but i think as
councillor cupid highlights
um there are reasons and there are there
are protocols and regulations that they
must follow
and i think it's the same token of uh
when our own planning officers uh
recommend approval of an application
that we're not happy with
um i don't think it's appropriate that
we go and chastise them for that i think
we have to accept that they have a job
to do
and we might not like the way that they
or the opinion that they've come to on
that
but that's why it's our job as elected
members to
uh to really raise awareness within our
community get people to submit views
based on local knowledge what they know
of the local roads
what they know about traffic conditions
and situations etc
and i think that's our job as local
members and it's the job of our
planning committee to consider those
those issues
uh in the round together with the the
opinions that they get from dcc highways
officers i think the idea of a a
of a scrutiny committee discussion on it
isn't isn't necessarily a bad one
however we have to accept that
scrutiny committees need to be
independent of the council and i think
it's better if they can
come up with their own agendas and i
know that all of our scrutiny committees
are already busy with
quite a few uh important topics that
they're investigating at the minute so i
wouldn't want
for this to just go away uh and
um be added to a list of a future uh
scrutiny agenda topic
when actually as as councillor cupid's
suggesting we can deal with it
uh now we can we can provide briefings
that we can
it doesn't have to necessarily be
limited to planning committee members we
can open that up to other members
to ensure that they have the opportunity
to talk to highways officers
um to to to have that dialogue and
feedback
uh some of their frustrations so i'm
sure we all share
so for the same reason as councillor
cupid i won't be supporting the motion
uh or the amendment but i do think that
this is an issue that we can
uh do more on and hope that we can do
that in the coming months
[Music]
uh thank you chair uh i put my hand up
to speak just before alex
uh our uh our leader spoke so
i'm afraid i'll be reiterating some of
our leaders points
i was going to make the point on the
amendment that uh scrutiny should be
deciding they should be independent and
they should be deciding their own topics
on what to scrutinize
and i don't believe the council should
be giving instruction to them
uh so for me uh if there is an issue
like this
it gets taken by whoever uh by council
barca and it gets taken
uh direct to one of those scrutiny
committees they can look at it and they
can decide on it there
if they wish to choose it as a topic um
for me it's what the scrutiny committees
have been used in the past
it's not under this administration
they've been used to criticize other
councils
now i know in their uh in their terms of
reference
you can look and scrutinize other
councils and other bodies it can be done
but it's done
been done far too much uh in the past so
for me i
like to concentrate with the scrutiny
scrutiny committees and we scrutinize
things that we can change and have an
active
role in we can make real changes at our
own council in this administration
uh so i won't be supporting that
amendment and as for the motion itself
it's just one more mixed-up motion from
the lib dems
speaking about improvements responsible
planning and the rest
and it's attacking the county council
it's just one more so i won't be
supporting that either
thank you thank you
councillor barker the right to reply on
the amendment
i don't know what i don't know what uh
what we're doing we
constitutionally ross is going xander do
you want to help me out
yeah cancer shipments should be allowed
to speak before councillor barker
how am i okay
thank you chair um
it does concern me that we again kicking
the can down uh talking about kicking
the can down the road
uh on another issue um i i i won't
support them and
out of principle because i think that
this is something that we need to
approach the county council about now i
think if it goes to a committee and we
all know we've all sat on committees
it's it's a game of ping pong about
who's going to deal with the issue does
anything actually come of it
and everything else and i just don't
think we need to be going down that
route we need to actually
address this issue and you can call it
criticizing it's actually pointing out
the obvious that the information we're
getting is not consistent
um councillor foster you're well aware
that it's not consistent given that you
sit on the phone
committee with me and we have these
discussions many many a time in planning
committee
so i think let's just do something about
it let's
pass this let's write to the county
council let's get them involved in the
discussion
talk about where things can improve the
types of information we need on the
planet
all counselors can be involved instead
of that's
there's no point is just kicking this
issue down the road when we know it's an
issue that needs tackling now
so i think um i'm going to be voting
against the
amendment and then for the motion as
it's currently written
thank you councillor barker
yeah thanks uh it looks like we're both
going to lose anyway
so it don't really matter we were trying
to come
with that to an amendment as a
compromise really i've listened
i'm sorry charlotte i can't really hear
you very well uh but
i've got the message i understand that
there's certain
things you can do within the council to
to address some of these but
uh from my perspective uh it were about
a lot like councillor barry's just said
it's about making it more public
uh and uh so that the community can get
involved and people can see and it's
also about the communication between the
two councils
from the public's perspective not
particularly as councillors
i accept my council foster's argument
that
shall be dictating to to scrutiny what
they look at
but it is an issue that that's been
ongoing for a long while
i don't accept the argument that we've
criticized other councils on a regular
basis
i don't know where you got that one from
but anyway
we'll let that one lie and uh so i'll
stick with the amendment it's gonna get
voted down
and then uh we'll vote for the amendment
but i don't think
i can vote for for the original motion
because it it does imply that the
officers at
county council are not doing the job
properly and and i don't think that's a
fair comment either
so let's look at vote do we want the
amendment
and then we go back to original is that
right
sarah
yeah sorry yes that's right uh the the
uh motion mover
cancer hancock has a right to reply
immediately before the vote so now he
has a right to reply if he'd like to
exercise it
if this is for the amendment though is
he is
is he does he wait till the next bit no
he has a right to reply on the amendment
okay
thank you sarah do i have your consent
to
speak
yes thank you chair um i would like to
thank all members because um
that there's elements that everybody has
raised that i think i i agree with in to
some degree and
and alex i i actually and i know this is
a rare event i do actually agree with
yourself over the fact that it's no good
against scrutiny because it does just
kick it into long grass
so i oppose the amendment um the bit
where
i mean council barclays absolutely spot
on the problem is that most of these are
desktop exercises and that's why
we're getting the kind of reports that
that we are getting
um in terms of him saying that we are
being critical of people not doing their
job right
the reality is they're not adhering to
the mppf and they're also
they have admitted both to the planning
inspectorate and in meetings
that they don't do what they should be
doing so i think it it is a case of
of actually highlighting that fact um
going back to councillor cupid's point
fully respect what she what she's saying
and i absolutely agree with it i don't
see that this is actually something that
is separate to it and i think it can be
done alongside
so i i respectfully acknowledge what uh
what the labor group is saying and their
amendment i don't agree with it i don't
support it
but i do think that we need to press on
with this
in terms of of again what council dell
was saying about individual members and
having their input you're absolutely
right but of course the key thing that
we're told in planning and our planning
officers do a
good job but as they always say they can
only work on what they've got and if
we're
challenging something that the experts
have said differently it won't stand up
at appeal
so unless we can actually get them to
change what they're saying which is a
very difficult job i know on occasion it
happens
but it's very rare we can't challenge it
it doesn't hold up at appeal so it is a
problem
um so that that's my position i i don't
support the amendment but i do ask
members to support the
the original motion
thank you can the government governance
manager now lead us
in the vote thank you thank you chair so
uh members are asked to vote for against
or abstain
on the amendment put forward by
counselor nigel barker i'm just going to
share my screen with you
now so that you can see that motion i'm
sorry the amendment
so the amendment is a deletion of the
final part of the paragraph there which
i've crossed out
to refer this matter to a scrutiny
committee to research the regulations
that highways officers
have to work to and how any comments
from highways
can be communicated clearer at planning
meetings
so if members would be able to all of
them turn
on your cameras so that we can clearly
um
see your vote for against your abstain
when requested to by the chair
so chair if you can just give a moment
for the members to turn on their cameras
i'll just prompt those who haven't
turned on us yet
chair that's all members with their
cameras on leave the vote for
against daughter of staying those four
please raise my hand
i made that 25 chair
those members against
with that 29 chair there are five votes
against
in the council chamber
okay the amendment falls unless there
are any abstentions sorry chairman
i don't see any abstentions um remote
later
in which case the motion will fall
and you um and you revert to the
original motion
as put to the meeting
need to go back to the original
motion anybody wish to speak on the
original motion
[Music]
thank you i think we've covered
everything so we may as well just go
straight to the vote thank you
thank
chair you we will be moving to a vote by
show of hands
um on the motion as submitted in the
agenda by councillor hancock
um all members have their cameras on so
you're welcome to lead the four against
abstain vote
all those councilors for
that's three votes for chair
thank you
[Music]
uh
at 44. are five votes against in the
county chairman
are there any abstentions chair
any extensions
i can see one obsession remotely chair
so there was 44 votes against
that the motion would fall
can we just check does the 44 include
the five from the council chamber
oh geez um no it didn't um we can we can
double check the the numbers on the
voting
um
[Music]
i think i think the numbers on that may
be slightly incorrect
the majority of members have voted
against the motion sorry sarah
so is that 44 plus five so 49
could we clarify the numbers please
because that makes more people vote
than we've got here that's correct would
you like for me to rerun the voting or
are you happy to accept
um the majority of the meeting
okay thank you chair apologies members
on the counting there would you be kind
enough
to turn on all of your cameras
oh come on dave you're not going to win
hey let's be
we've got to do it properly though
[Music]
thank you chad um would you like to
leave the voucher
all those four
tera i can see three votes four
those are ghosts
foreign
[Music]
this thing
[Music]
from the council chamber please no that
doesn't that's remotely sorry
so that's 37 against plus five they're
in the chamber
so that's um three votes for 42 against
and one abstention
and the motion would fall on that vote
motion's being lost
[Music]
we will now move to the next motion can
i invite councillor ross shipman
to move motion b on the agenda
thank you uh um this is another planning
related one
um but this is just to um increase the
capacity of the
council um and its planning enforcement
um area because there's so many
different
developments that are going on around
where the developers
just pay no district in no regard
whatsoever
to the conditions that are put on their
developments
and you know i can think of something
outward particularly
where you know it the traffic management
plans are just
totally disregarded and there's just
issues developing from that and then
when you try and get planning to do
something about it
they're stretched they're the resources
are thin on the ground so this is about
you know increasing that cost for
enforcement
to uh take place i do um
i think though um and i may be wrong and
i'm sure someone from the cabinet might
be able to correct me but i saw
something on one of the cabinet
um papers about
planning and enforcement so i didn't
know if something had gone through
that was about increasing the capacity
of planning enforcement or whether it
was just a generic plan about
you know what the council had plans to
do um
i think that went on last week went in
between my motion going on and this
canceled me
so i'll just send my motion straight to
uh cabinet group next time
that's me done so pretty simple
my system working i'd like to second
that one please
just to add to what council shipman says
um
i mean we are geographically a very
large
large district we have got a lot of
building projects on there i know for
for a point through the through the uh
through the summer i don't know whether
they've actually come out of that
yet but we actually had one part-time
person doing planning enforcement
which clearly logistically is the
physical impossibility on that person
so we we need to look at increasing
capacity on oil which is a stretch but
it's an area where we have got a lot of
issues
and and by pure logistics on the size of
size of the district
we need additional capacity in that area
so nothing more to add than that thank
you chair
thank you council cupid um
thank you chair um so yeah i think
uh you sort of get the nail on the head
that this came into the cabinet
um last week so to some extent i think
it's already sorted
um i don't think i have to say
that i don't think it's realistic to
expect an enforcement officer
on every development in this district as
much as i'd like it i'm not sure
it's achievable anywhere because in
reality i think enforcement is as much
about
action as well as through monitoring
sites and
labour members may well remember from my
time in opposition and officers
certainly go over the last year
that i feel really strongly about
enforcement um in reality
we inherited quite a mess here from the
previous administration
um where for many years this council
didn't even have one full-time
planning enforcement officer and was
essentially trying to stick faster on
increased demand of the planning system
through extensive agency support this
has taken time to fix over the last year
but we've been working on it
both our planning system and our
enforcement system have been a priority
for this administration since taking
control last year
it's been at the heart of our council
plan to review and invest in this area
so i can't support council shipman's
comments but
we only put it on when seeing the motion
because it was on a year ago
and it's not that full-sized there are
two actions
in the council plan to develop an
enforcement plan which came last week
and to review the structure of the
planning and the enforcement team
these would usually be completed by
march april time
but we're delayed due to covid and we've
been working on them
throughout the summer and took reports
of cabinet last week which i'm really
pleased we agreed
one of those reports just to offer a bit
of clarity
was the start of a new enforcement plan
um
which will set out what we accept of our
enforcement system
which will come to planning committee in
due course for approval
in a more resident friendly form but it
also sets out through that plan of clear
targets for responses and for monitoring
enforcement cases
those ward members and as residents we
know what's happening with breaches
and what action is being taken that
hasn't been done in this district before
and i think it's a really positive step
actually to try and monitor and keep a
closer handle on some other things
and secondly as you've seen from the
agreed cabinet papers we've agreed a
major investment in our planning service
more generally
which is important to both development
management but also to enforcement
it's an exempt report just for members
at the moment because of the staffing
indications
but the public headlines are that we're
doubling the size of our enforcement
team
and technical support investing in
development management so officers have
more resources to track development and
conditions
and make sure they're enforced and
investing in expertise as well
such as our horocultural and heritage
support which will again help in
enforcement cases
and say i can't discuss the full details
you should be able to see the report but
if you do
want to discuss the sort of staffing
issues that
led to that i'm happy to have sort of
discussions with you outside of
this county meeting um just as an
additional point
i think emotion misses the point to some
extent because it's been clear to me
over the last year that planning
enforcement is quite often not just the
responsibility of planning officers
it has to be a joint effort with
environmental health legal and others
which is why as an administration one of
our key priorities is enforcement just
as a general thing
as well as being written in the council
platinum we've also set up
regular corporate enforcement officer
group and to make sure there's no silo
working between those
different sections and i just want to
thank the officers
who've worked to introduce that and set
it up and with particularly thanks to
vicky dawson who needs that and
as the director and who've sort of
really driven that forward and as a
result i think we're making progress on
some really complex
long-running departmental enforcement
cases
and so we should have some headlines
there pretty soon um so whilst i'm
grateful to councillorship and for the
opportunity to set out all these
positive actions
um that have been taken to increase
enforcement i think this motion
is probably a year too late in the
council plan that long
um and so i can't say that you can claim
the credit counselor shipments
the efforts and the detail which is
lacking from this motion that have gone
into that work
um but i hope you'll support it and
therefore i won't be supporting this
notion because it's already done to a
large extent
thank you thanks for else
did you wish to speak
does anyone else wish to speak
[Music]
also shipment do you wish that sounds
your right to reply
yeah thank you chair um it's it's good
to hear actually councillor cupid um
talk about these things that are ongoing
in the background and uh there seems to
be some positive stuff coming through in
terms of enforcement
i'm probably thinking that we might as
well just pull the motion if if the
work's being done
it seems to me pointless to go through
with the whole voting process and
everything
when clearly there's some work to take
that forward so
um if uh it was a david who said
if david wants up for it we'll pull it
and then see what the um
paper that's going to come through to
planning says and then we can obviously
approach it at that point and see where
we go from there
sorry chess speaking earlier this is a
bit of a lag um
just to clarify um with with councillor
cupid i think she said this
but uh and obviously i don't want you to
commit on the stuffing thing obviously
out sideways
but you did say you are looking to
increase the capacity didn't you
withdrawing the motion thank you
thank
now you now move on to the third notion
uh i invite councillor nigel barker to
move motion c
on the uh
[Music]
thank you chair how am i on yeah
uh i'm sure everybody's aware of this
white paper that that's been produced
and
uh that's been referred to in this
motion
and i'm i'm sure you've all read some of
the criticism
uh comments that have been in the lg gru
stuff that we get
and other things i mean i've been
reading fact i've been reading too much
i've got
i've got papers here reams on them not
all left wing
but pressed by the way you know inside
housing and all that sort of stuff so
i have sort of been reading up on it
quite a bit
uh i think we can all agree and i think
even in all the comments that i've read
is that
the planning system is far from perfect
i think we'd all accept that and
and i know we keep going around with
this local plan and one thing or another
but i think we've got to be careful and
and i say this a lot is that
by improving things we ended up making
them worse and that seems to happen a
lot
as i can see sometimes
it's all done we got intentions but we
end up going backwards so
somewhere again it's uh
there's lots of implement implicitly
implementing this implications into this
paper i think
i've listed some of the concerns in that
motion the four bullet points
the first one i think is is about
government
setting housing limits and i know it was
something that we talked about
in local plan meetings when we used to
have them
i'm sure council armitage will will back
me up on that because he used to mention
it at virtually everyone
and where we got the six thousand six
hundred hours from
uh but it feels as though that's being
uh
made even stronger now um
that
the main issue for me mine is the second
one and it's about these
uh we're losing the the ability to
question things at planning committees
i think that they're setting up these
growth areas or renewal areas
especially the growth areas once a place
has been designated
as a growth area then they'll have
statutory
outline planning permission so that
means
that if somebody applies to building
that area
they get it whether or not the result of
that is the
opportunity for communities to comment
on
individual applications in those areas
are removed
and i think that's a big worry in all
these publications and
in effect the planning committee could
be made obsolete
that the involvement of the local
communities at planning
will be overridden uh the the basic
decisions will be made elsewhere
uh regards the third point and i accept
it may relate to urban areas
we shops and officers but it could also
impact tunnels at hackington kilimanjaro
clay cross
where there are empty shops and offices
that that
basically they can apply to turn them
into flats and things
and there's lots of examples where they
uh
are not great basically they're small
bed sets that are not really fit for
purpose
and the fourth point which is probably
less clear-cut and i and i understand
there's a claim that you could the fixed
new levy will fund road schools and
and stuff and discounted owners for
first-time buyers haven't read
but the problem is it's not clear how
this will work and it's
at the expense of doing away with sills
and 106's
uh funding which has been funding or
been a source of funding for affordable
housing around here
and my fear is and again i've read this
in all the stuff
it's not clear how that will impact on
areas like ours
as i alluded to in that last bit is that
as far as i understand areas with lower
land values will get less affordable
housing
because it's dependent on the the value
of the land
that they're built on so again it it so
to
like i've said it it's embedding
regional inequalities there's all those
issues
uh and therefore i'll move the motion as
printed
uh and ask the council to respond to the
consultation
as i've requested in that motion thank
you
oh and i think yeah go on i'll somebody
else is one
second yes is there a second
[Music]
i'll second thatcher
and this motion embodies the hypocrisy
of the
current government which talks about
devolution
while simultaneously trying to strip
local authorities
of any legitimate control over
development in their area
for all members irrespective of party
planning is one of the most
controversial issues we deal with i
doubt there isn't a single member in
this meeting who hasn't faced issues
from problematic developments in their
ward
be that a planning stage or when it goes
wrong because something that everyone
has cautioned against
gets approval simply because the current
framework
says it's okay
the proposals put forward by central
government are yet another example
of a housing policy designed solely to
address
london's needs by throwing the rest of
the country
under the bus local authorities need
greater empowerment
we need the authority to say exactly
what type of development is required to
meet the demand in our area
to help our 20 somethings get onto the
housing ladder
to provide to provide quality
accommodation for our older residents to
have the
opportunity to downsize the absolute
last thing that north east derbyshire
needs
are more homes designed to bring
commuters into the area
who contribute little in financial terms
to the local economy and you continue to
push the house prices
beyond the reach of the hard-working
local people
these proposals aren't acceptable to
northeast derbyshire
and the liberal democrats are proud to
support
our labour and hopefully conservative
and
independent colleagues on this motion
thank you chair
thank you
[Music]
thank you chair um i've got a couple of
points that i want to raise and mainly i
want to
put these towards the leader of the
council so if you can bear with me i'd
like to uh first refer
the leader to point one of our motion
which is the proposals will give
government the powers to set arbitrary
housing
delivery numbers for each authority
people
agree with the local residents and the
fellow councillors that the decisions
made around development within our
district should remain the
responsibility
of local people and their
representatives and not at the hands
of central government who know nothing
about our area or the people that live
in it
or does he feel that keeping the local
people in the dark and doing away with
democracy
is the right way forward so that's my
first question in relation to this
um some information i'd like from the
leader
i'm sorry is council barrier where she's
only able to speak once in relation to a
debate so i don't know if he had more
questions than that he wanted me to
answer
larry yes i do actually um
the other well the other thing i'd like
to raise again in relation to the motion
is part two of that motion where it says
they will remove the opportunity
to communities to comment to comment on
individual planning applications and
again
can the leader assure this council that
he will go against the proposed white
paper
that central government have produced
and stand with his fellow councillors
and constituents in saying
no to the proposals and fight to keep
the local
the planning local for local people to
determine
what gets built and to ensure that local
democracy continues to thrive that's my
haddon thank you
thank you i mean the question of keeping
local people
in the dark on planning was your first
one it's a very interesting one because
i think i have to say that
that was labor uh northeast alberta
labour's
uh policy during the last administration
they kept every community in the in the
dark about the local plan
they didn't plan positively or engage
residents about where development should
take place
so i do have to take a degree of umbrage
with that with that statement
uh i of course believe that local people
should be involved
in involved in uh implanting decisions i
believe in localism
and actually if you look at what you're
saying in relation to this motion you
talk about top-down housing targets
it was actually the conservative
government that abolished
labour's top-down housing targets under
the regional spatial strategies
prior to the mppf being introduced are
there issues within the white paper that
concern me yes but there are other
aspects of the white paper that i think
are positive and i think that we have to
engage constructively
i don't think that as councillor cupid
is going to come on and say
in in our group's response to this
motion i don't think that the
the points that this motion is is making
around the white paper are actually
legitimate that the white paper is an
extremely high level
discussion around potential planning
changes it does not say that the
government is steamrolling ahead with
xyz policies
it talks about um it talks about some
high-level different proposals and it's
our job as a council to engage with that
and and make representations and and
feedback the views of of our
uh ourselves our planning officers and
our our councilor colleagues
but i don't think we just we should we
should buy hookline and sink it
everything that your motion suggests
because i think quite a lot of it
actually is is based on hearsay
not based on the actual white paper
document itself
um and i just think that the the degree
of uh
of cynicism i have for the comments
around that later the labour group have
made around
keeping people in the dark um it's just
your hypocrisy from my perspective
thank you chair
[Music]
councillor cooper thank you chair
um yeah i echo councillor dale's um
comments fully um and just sort of
expand on them a little bit um i think
you know i welcome the discussion on the
planning night paper
but i'm disappointed by that this is the
way you've chosen to do it
we could have quite a constructive
discussion but you've come forward with
what is essentially a sensationalist and
understanding your emotion
and you've asked quite a few questions
today
the client's point have you actually
read the white paper or just the
sort of the commentary around it from
the left-wing press
you know where in the 84-page document
does it mention
any of these assertions there's no
mention of some charters
unregulated development removing
commenting on individual applications
embedding regional inner policies none
of those things are mentioned
and indeed just on the first page it
clearly states exactly the opposite
that they're cutting red tape standards
and this government doesn't just want to
build houses
you know i think it's already been
mentioned today that from the time we've
spent
just today in this chamber discussing
planning the planning system
isn't working in our world in our part
of the world
and i think it hasn't been working for
president you know you've made a
political motion and counsellor there
was already said that
it wasn't working over the labour
administration it be that the local plan
the amount of speculative development
that's happened
or the proposals filled in the green
belt over 2000
houses or the failure to properly use
section 106s
which i know you've touched on several
times today but that failure to use
section 106 as
fully has meant some developments
perhaps to choose between education
health or affordable housing
contributions which should never have to
happen you shouldn't have to choose do
you want the school or
vulnerable housing i'm totally opposed
to that
um yeah the conservative administration
here at this council
has spent a year trying to get us out of
as many of these messes as possible
so i actually welcome the white paper in
the sense that it's having a discussion
on these issues
and trying to change it so we can never
have the perfect storm like we've
currently hopped off in this district
and i've had for the last decade or so
um
to go on to just a few of the the points
that you've gone through already
to sell one of the false news stories
and
given your previous and willingness
consoles on the left
understand you wouldn't like it but to
me placing a greater emphasis on
communities and residents having more
say in the local plan
earlier on which is what the aim of the
white paper is
seems a positive one to me to choose
another point and again to go back to
infrastructure the council's reliance on
section 106 is
rather than a settled community
infrastructure lately as the
two currently available options and that
was the decision of the previous labor
administration
as left issues we've all been trying to
resolve as i've just said
and we've already discussed that today
with highways so
i actually welcome that the white paper
quotes the opposite of that
by saying that planning obligations are
broadly considered to be uncertain as
opaque
and faith as we all recognize and that
it's very difficult
to and uncertain to know the level of
affordable housing
which that development will bring i
think we should all agree with that
point in the white paper
and i welcome the chance to put forward
a locally based infrastructure level
but very rarely delivered by developers
in this area
and to go back to what i started on i
think the truth is
the draft white paper doesn't say any of
the speculative claims in this motion
it's specifically high level in terms of
its proposals
things such as zoning greater emphasis
on local plans and community engagement
from the very beginning and throughout
and again i will continue to fully
support that there should be engagement
throughout the planning process
and introducing design codes as well
which i think is a really positive thing
so we can have influence on the side of
new developments
and from that i think the white paper is
proposing headline ideas because it's a
genuine consultation
they're specifically asking people to
engage with local examples of what will
and won't work
and that's already been confirmed to us
as a council and well thought out
responses to shape the detail
so i think if we're constructed here
this is a real chance to shape
a positive planning future rather than
just attacking
the white people with loads of you know
comments and scare stories
um so i think it's a conservative
administration that's what we're going
to do we're going to be constructive
about it
i'm already working with officers up the
council's response based on facts and
local examples across the district
rather than on speculation so i can't
support this motion
but i would say the final point that
everyone can submit their own
consultation responses and i would
indeed urge everyone
here today to do so whilst the council
will submit a response in fall for the
district
i think it's only right that board
members outline their preferences
and views for each of their orders
because we all know our wards are
different
so i think that's what we should do as
well and so yeah i can't support
promotion but i would urge everybody to
put their own comments forward
the white paper and the council will
certainly be putting comments forward
thank you
you wish to exercise your right to reply
yes please as has everybody else known
[Music]
counselor [ __ ] man sorry
thank you for that chair um i do support
the motion i mean
counselor cupid needs to stop kicking
another can down the road because
it's all well and good saying we can
also commit comments um
and you know we can our voices across
the whole point of this motion is that
the council submits a voice
we are the voice is a much more powerful
it comes from the council as an
organization than if um
all those individuals submit something
saying would like something to be a
certain way
the whole point is that this motion says
that we they don't get me wrong there
are some good stuff in the white paper
but ultimately if we are giving away
some of our democracy or some of our say
as a local authority
any good thing in that policy is is
irrelevant to that point
i mean it's what it's worrying to hear
you saying that you support giving away
the decision-making power that this
authority would have because i mean if
you if you're supporting the white paper
that's what you're agreeing to you may
you may not you may
you may not think um i just supported a
few
simple things in it you know but at the
end of the day
it's going to um cause problems for the
strict strip when there's a
planning committee especially trying to
make decisions um and we're being
bypassed
on what essentially would be big
developments in growth areas
then we're pretty much in a dire
position there so i think as
a local authority we need to be
submitting comments
um saying that we do oppose some of the
things in it
um and i mean and the white papers all
tries to address
the amount of houses that are being
built but the reality is that
nine out of ten planning applications
that we get passed
so by speeding up development um
and fast tracking it without the local
authority having to say
it's not going to bring us any more
housing that we want in this local area
in fact
it'll bring more inappropriate
developments in the wrong place
and some will be in your ward and then
you'll come to a planning committee and
tell us about
how it's a terrible development and all
this other stuff
um but that you'll be bypassed so you
won't ever have the opportunity to try
and actually defend it
um i just think that as a local
authority we need to stand up and make
sure that our voices are heard
and i'm not just talking about
individual counselors i'm talking about
the whole organization
so i will be supporting this motion um
so yeah thanks a lot
thank you councillor cooper appointed
clarification
thank you jay i just wanted to clarify
for council shipment that i didn't say
any of the things that you just said
indeed i explicitly said that i
completely support planning
remaining as a local um
local community engagement throughout
the process and i
remember myself saying throughout the
process so and again
on the second point of clarification the
council will be submitting a response
but as i said in my initial speech
not on this basis that's quite a
negative response we're going to
actively engage
with examples of what will work in our
area and what won't thank you
thank you councillor
thank you thank you chair uh um as being
said i think it's um quite a pity
that um some of the good aspects in this
white paper
and some of the good changes that
they're proposing there and can be
worked on
aren't going to be um within the gift of
the local planning authority to
implement
and that's going to be taken away from
them and it's not surprising to hear
um our conservative side of this
council supporting that as uh the
you know the the the tory objective from
central government down
is to dumb down and get rid of local
authorities and local accountability and
this is another
nail in that coffee this planning for
the future document talks about
beautiful housing and beautiful uh
communities
and if local authorities are to lose
their ability to approve the details of
new developments
by what means can user local communities
be
taken into account when determining
what's beautiful in terms of
housing and communities
and how can those local communities
continue to have any
real force planning control
with this centralizing of the planning
regulation
would effectively pass from local
planning authorities
such as borough councils and others to
property developers
the very people who stand to gain huge
profits from construction in reality
and local people won't have much to say
about that
there'll be a klondike type gold rush
to large property developers at the
expense of the voice of local people
i'm not surprised that the conservative
members on this council supporting that
propping up this flight
that's in effect what they're planning
to do and deny the right to local people
and local authorities to have say in
determining what happens in their
communities
i'll be supporting this motion chair
yeah sorry there's a lot there i've been
making notes i don't know where to start
firstly i have read it the white paper
it went very exciting i've got to be
honest and to be honest for a white
paper there weren't a lot of detail
there to be honest
i didn't find and yes i have relied on
others uh supposedly outing experts or
whatever to
pick the bones out of it and and come up
with critiques of it
and and that's where i've got some of
these things from uh
they are experts and like i said at the
beginning they're not from
any left there are a couple of left-wing
articles i'll get that
but most of them are from inside housing
and local government papers so that's
where the critiques come from
uh and and again uh i'd accept
you know that that like i said at the
beginning it needs improving
uh and also i think i alluded to it
everything while being a bit sarcastic
if we'd had
local plant steering groups we could
easily have discussed this that would
have been a perfect vehicle
where officers the planning experts
could have brought it to us
and we as a a group could have discussed
it and come up with a council's
uh contribution uh comments towards this
this uh white paper and i think that
would have been the
well it still is still could be the best
place to do it
uh and again i i thought i have agree
well i always agree with steve pickering
it's it's more geared
as you'd expect towards the big
businesses the uh
the big developers of the world to to
get on and do stuff
as a lot of uh the planning legislation
has been for a long while
and it does get forgot about and it does
frustrate me
when we were in control nobody ever
mentions that the other side
all right the council is uh
recommending acceptance of these big
developments
but there's a lot of pressure put on
from the developers
that if we do it wrong they'll go to
call and they'll win
they've got the money and and the big
money people
that's where the the the problem lies
with planning not particularly at our
end
it's they've got the influence and they
they are
influencing government to every turn and
that that's
that's a worry and if that's why we end
up with rough end at stick at our end
because then we've got to argue the case
against these big developers
um and again i i still
i'm going to have back a little bit to
beginning and i do feel this white paper
it
it moves it does
link into the unitary authority stuff
because both will ultimately move
any decision making further and further
away from local democratic
accountability
and and it does seem strange to me that
we've got local conservative councillors
uh promote gin and voting for
centralization which is taking away any
decision making
further away from local people and
communities
uh and and again it does link in i never
got answer to my first question
councillor dale that somewhere that line
you've got a conflict of interest
between the leader of this district
council
and a county council on the cabinet of a
county council
where you're ultimately trying to take
over
and abolish the same council you sat on
and sooner or later
you're going to have to put your cards
on the table on that front
and again going back to the white paper
it's obviously going to get voted down
but if we open that that
local planned steering wheel port uh and
actually discuss it on the
on the with experts there
then i i'm more than happy to take you
up on that but obviously i'd ask you to
support this resolution as it stands
thank you
thank you jerry if i could come in
another point of clarification i was
very clear at the
beginning of the meeting with councillor
barker that our
uh preference as with all other all the
other nine
uh councils in the county is the vision
derbyshire that's what we are pushing
for
um but to to have a head in the sound
approach uh given what derby city have
done
is frankly the wrong uh thing to do from
my perspective the county has to keep
its options open
and we as a district council also have
to do the same
uh so i think it's i think it's you
purposely
misrepresenting what i'm saying in my
position on this i've been absolutely
clear that we we're supporting vision
derbyshire
vision derbyshire is the only way that i
can see that we
uh retain our district council and
actually the priority isn't to this
district council or to county council
my priorities for the residents of this
district that's why i chose to get into
involved in politics
and to represent local people in my area
as a counselor
thank you thank you
can the governance manager now leaders
in the bones
thank you chair um if all members would
be kind enough to
turn on their cameras
okay chair all the members cameras are
on and
they are voting on the motion submitted
by council barca as written on the
agenda
okay all those four
so
so
so
d22
apologies chair and technical issues my
end my screens are flicking around i'm
just going to do another count i'm sorry
uh counselors if you could keep your
hands raised
on the second can i make that 29 chair
against
say apologies chair from my position i'm
having a technical issue with the
members um
screens flicking around from different
views
and um and i'm uncertain of whether i'm
counting
members at the same time may i request
chair that i do this by roll call to
ensure that the vote is correct
is that permissible
[Music]
okay my apologies chair um through you
i'll just um
do a vote by roll call if members could
indicate clearly fought against or
abstain
counsel and cliff
[Music]
um
[Music]
face i've ever seen um apologies chair
there is a member that's speaking
over the feed would all members be kind
of just to meet themselves
apologies i've had to meet a number of
councillors on on that
um check through you then um running a
vote by roll call um counselor aunt
cliff
so council armitage
master armitage
against how's the barker
gaza barry
ansa barry
kevin bone
oh
thank you oh geez i got uh councillor
cooper four
councillor cornwell oh
how's the cupid again
council dale again
councillor dayton against
councillor elliott
that's evans against
my apologies
i'm struggling with my sound so my
apologies
can i just say that we're both on the
same wireless here
and our bandwidth is uh struggling we're
both on the same
internet connection i'll let you go back
to angelique
all right uh counselor angelique foster
against casa mark foster
against councillor jean fennell
four
councillor gomez rini against
castle hall against
for a member that's on the line
thank you my apologies counselor hello
is that betty councillor betty hill
there's councillor betty hill
he's had to leave the meeting about an
hour and a half an hour ago
okay thank you um carter and holmes
how to ann holmes i think she may has
left
i think she's left the meeting looking
at it sorry answer carol huckabee
okay
alpha jones four
how's the canyon advanced
house for kerry paul
councilman lewis against
councillor liggett abstain
council lilly
castle morley
the jerry morley
council of pickering
council powell
catherinic against
casa ridgeway
stone council shipment
council shipments stuck in the waiting
room as connections dropped
um i don't have uh council shipment in
the waiting room
oh he's he's messaging me and he's
trying to get through and calm
he has voted in the show of hands
already though i don't know how you want
to take that
okay well we'll see if the connection
rejoins him in a moment i'll keep an eye
on the room
castle stone paul
thanks for tate against
counsel
against castle windley
oh that's a b
right
and cancer p right
that's a p right
and
can i ever go
nikki can i just ask whether you got
councillor morley's vote
because he he was on mute and he whilst
he was saying four i don't know if you
heard him
no i don't have i've got a note next to
councilman morley and councillor shipman
who were not present
counselor morley which way would you
like to indicate to vote
i can see you're not being four could
you give me a thumbs up if that's
correct
okay so that would make that 19 cancer
[ __ ] man are you on the line now
okay chair um on that basis then the
vote is concluded you have um 18 votes
sorry 19 votes for
23 against with four abstentions
which emotion falls
i was gonna say i've got more
abstentions than that
i've got five abstentions
[Music]
like we're all doing to start with at
the beginning of the meeting
be a permission chair i can issue an
electronic vote
yes
that's been launched here
huh
still have a few more members to vote
that are joining us remotely
just a few final seconds left
there are no further votes coming in so
i'll end the polling at that point
and share the revolts on the results on
your screen
um out of 39 members that voted during
the the poll there there were 17
for 19 against with three abstentions
chair would you like to take a vote
within the chamber
[Music]
again with three abstentions
in the chamber and two against that
would make it 17 4
21 against with six abstentions
[Music]
germany are you happy to accept those
figures
yes
um and with 21 voting against that would
make the motion fall
next one is um we'll now move to the
next motion
about council of pan windley move motion
d
on the agenda councilor windsor
[Music]
and i took down
thank you councilwoman thank you chair
[Music]
no urgent business
so i prepared the meeting closed
thank you
you